[MUSIC PLAYING]
So you're a studious
person who's
watched every episode of
Android Performance Patterns.
OK, not every one-- Colt
does a lot of videos,
and he usually just
says things like,
don't use up too much battery.
Make efficient HTTP requests.
ENUMs are like gremlins.
You know, all that
normal perf stuff.
So by now you know that you
don't want a bloated APK.
You don't just let unneeded
resources sit around
in your build.
But despite knowing this, you
may still have a bloated APK.
So how's that even possible?
I'm David East, and
just because you're
being frugal your
resources doesn't
mean that the libraries you've
included will do the same.
Take this common scenario.
You're using the Google
Play services library
to build an app that just
uses a single API like Maps.
But your code is not using it
in a logging functionality.
Well, the library still includes
all the assets and layouts
that allow someone to log in.
Even though you may only like
the way this button looks,
you don't need the
resource in your APK.
So, as you can't manually
purge this resource,
it gets included in your
final package application.
And it's stuff like this
that leads to bloated APKs.
Well, we have the Gradle tool
chain, and it's here to help.
Gradle can statically
analyze all of your code
to find the assets that
aren't being reference
and then automatically pull
them out of your build.
And the party doesn't
just stop there.
Gradle will also go
through and analyze strings
in your code for
cases where you're
doing things like constructing
a path name at run time
and scrape through
your assets folder,
opening up text,
CSS, and JavaScript
files to check there as well.
To get this started, just
enable the shrink resources flag
in your Gradle configuration.
You'll also need to
set minify enabled.
This will turn on
proguard, which
just removes code
from link libraries
that your app is it using.
Know, though, that this
needs to be done first.
Otherwise, Gradle
gets super confused
because it still
think that there's
pass-referencing assets.
Once you've done this,
though, our earlier scenario
is looking a lot better.
After Google Play
services is linked in,
Gradle sees that no paths
use the login resources
and exclude it from
your APK, which
is exactly what we wanted.
A little bit of a
warning, though, there
might be some false
positives or false negatives.
You might find that
some of your assets
are getting cut when you wanted
them kept and some of them
are getting kept when
you wanted them cut.
We can fix this, though,
with the tools keep
and the tools discard attributes
to set up the desired behavior.
But before you get all
resource-cutting crazy,
it's important to
understand that Gradle
has its limitations.
Gradle won't ditch
your resolution folders
or multiple language folders.
These may be needed at run time,
and the compiler can't really
know ahead of time what the
end user is going to need.
So managing your resources
requires some extra work
on your part, but it's a big
performance gain for the user.
And experiences for the user is
what performance is all about.
Find out more by watching the
rest of Android Performance
Patterns content,
AKA the Colt Show.
And don't forget to join our
Google+ community for other
great content as well.
So sweat the small stuff,
but don't freak out.
And remember that perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]